in a time of global pandemic soaring
unemployment
massive wildfires and racial strife
it feels like the world is going to hell
but it's not
there's a huge amount of progress that's
taking place that a lot of people just
don't take into account
especially smart people who are
attending to the real problems of the
world
but not getting the long-term view which
is what we try to provide in this
particular book
ronald bailey is recent science
correspondent and the co-author of the
new book
10 global trends every smart person
should know
bailly and the cato institutes mario and
tupi take a long-term look
at positive global developments that
have been mostly
under-reported or ignored for instance
the world's poorest people have gotten
richer at an
accelerating pace the the natural state
of humanity is
abject poverty and one of the one of the
benchmarks you can look at is what they
call absolute poverty threshold which is
living on a dollar ninety per day per
person what we find is is around 1820
84 of the world's population lived on
less than that
a day and that that took 160 years for
that to get down to only 41
160 years but since then it's now below
10 in fact the last data we have from
the world bank is down to 8.6
and will probably be 5 or less by 2030
if current trends continue
the planet has gotten significantly
greener too in the last 40 years
most people don't know that actually the
forests around the globe have been
expanding since the 1980s
and kind of amazingly so of course
there's deforestation taking
place in places like brazil and so forth
but if you look
broadly across the entire globe what you
find is is that
the forests have expanded since the
1980s to an area that's
about the size of alaska and montana
combined basically
800 000 square miles of land the world
is also getting safer
for the poor in particular we're looking
at a rate of deaths from natural
disasters that includes earthquakes
tornadoes
flooding hurricanes what have you
all natural disasters as you could think
of them and what we find is that over
over the period of time is uh the rate
of death from
natural disasters and remember world
population has increased four times
since
uh the beginning of the century has has
declined
99 percent and more a major
environmental problem is climate change
left unchecked it is literally an
existential threat to the health of our
planet
and our very survival the world is going
to end in 12 years if we don't address
climate change bailly says these claims
are based on a misreading of u.n
climate change reports there's no cliff
that we're running off of
all it means is well it's going to be
warmer than 1.5 degrees most
likely temperature increases will cause
real problems
but bailly says we're equipped to deal
with them thanks to technology
and economic growth climate change is
going to become a significant problem
but my best guess is that technology
will have the wealth and the technology
for future generations will to be able
to adapt to it and
to start ameliorating what the what
problems that do arise
there will be sea level rise and people
will have to retreat from the coast
but they're not going to have to retreat
tomorrow bailly attributes global
progress to better ideas about how to
organize society
let's sum it up with the word the
enlightenment happen basically the
enlightenment
essentially what happened is democracy
is a way to decide who gets to wield
power
and to be able to throw that out the
second thing is is that we ended up
basically
with uh free markets is that all the
sudden we had property rights and
and there was respect for the rule of
law the the third stool of this
and i think this is the most important
one is called
liberal science how we decide what the
truth is
and it's essentially radical notion of
free speech
is everybody gets to criticize
everybody else and there are no
consequences other than
you being shunned for that criticism and
so
it goes from the worst blog posts on the
planet to peer-reviewed science to today
or the most rigorous thing
everything gets checked by everybody
else and that really speeds up
innovation
if human progress is so ubiquitous why
don't we hear about it more
so what we have is a news media that
obviously focuses on what
sells and that is bad news good news is
not news
bad news is news to build a house takes
months
years to do to burn it down takes an
hour
another glitch of course is the progress
hides itself
as things get better and better all the
time we we start we move on go all right
we've got that win
we just take it for granted and what
we're trying to do with this book is to
not let people take it for granted
and let you and remind people this is
what has happened
and look to the future if we keep the
same institutions that enabled this
then much more of it will happen in the
[Music]
future